growing up
my family wasn't there for me it was
difficult and I need to set something
for my kids an Empire to leave for them
my family was poor I definitely would
not absolutely want my kids to go
through this how did you feel when you
got when you got a yes from an agent oh
no that was the best thing ever I it was
baffling I was like it was real this is
real yeah yeah why was it so quick the
second time
[Music]
I'd never doubt it since we started to
get these rent to rent just keep going
this is why you're doing it this is why
you're doing it remember where you're
coming from remember how it was hard for
you
and that's my why
that's my way
how was the process of setting up your
Enterprise was it easy or hard it was so
hard
the amount of notes that we got
it was like off-putting if we weren't on
The Mastermind call and just being
around other people how many no's did
you get how many we had a lot of notes
so many must have been hundreds and to
know we start up in let's say April and
um
it didn't take that long it took about
two months isn't it yeah but two months
is long two months is still long it is
when you're getting no I have to know
and then when we hit the first one
sometime June yeah
and that was Derek with her agent
then we said okay from there onwards we
just keep get going confident that the
confidence bill
and as you said in the in the learning
those learning material you know just
just keep following the process and
that's what we were doing we're just
following it out we keep folding up and
keep filling up and then once that first
one come I think they just start to come
back to us right we don't need to phone
up anymore do you own any Properties or
do you just control everything we don't
own anything that we are renting we are
renting but residential we don't know a
residential home cool so you don't own
any investment properties but you're
making a full-time salary from
properties that you don't own yeah
you're making what about two three grand
a month yeah from rent to rent
so talk to me about how you like why you
decided you're you're in a good job what
is it that you do Emma I'm an electrical
engineer by a trade I work for the
railway and um
I honestly I didn't I was just surfing
the net one day and I saw Evan's video
pop up and I was like gosh
and then I said Julia as soon as she
came home I I was like you need to watch
this what's happening and I was like
who's this summer you know I never knew
about somewhere and I saw that and then
when I saw the evidence video I was like
so inspiring my daughter said let's
watch it together and watch it and then
you know we've been to the first one
first one pound course in in Birmingham
I think in end in February end of
February
and um
we're so means um what was going on so
we say okay well let's purchase a few
packages and purchase a few packets
never go down to the academy at the same
time but
we start off with rent to rent
accelerator at HMO and and the deal is
selling oh service accommodation service
accommodation and we we've done it there
and yeah that's how we get started up
you know we just by coming to that one
part course in in Birmingham and then
after then we we follow through with
another one in Newcastle where was that
that was a day selling
yes that was this time we buy the D7
package there okay what you found the
deal at the deal selling masterclass no
no we didn't find a deal we just come to
the novel one pound course okay the New
Castle yeah and that was the detailing
my um course you were running up there
our our crash course up there so we come
up there and then we buy the package and
they say no we go back we went back home
and say let's start let's start do
something about this as well
and they just keep going and and I think
followed into April that's when we
really decide to come into it full time
yeah and and join the academy so how who
out of the two of you who's the one
hitting the phones and getting rejected
we're both phoned around
um I feel like
for me the the process that hustling
said if you've got quite a few where you
you don't mind you getting a no there
and then
um it's okay because you can just say
next next
and there was
um some days like okay I don't want to
do this anymore let me have a break let
me have a break yeah I guess the pain
wasn't there and my why didn't kick in
then because if it had
um I would have just continued but the
next day is like okay let's try again
and the key the key key is being around
other people that have done it they are
doing net they are getting those as well
as us so it was like okay
and even when we were getting those
notes just jump jumping on the
Mastermind call at nighttime and you
listen to The Other Guys success
the next day is just kind of spray you
one you know let's make some more phone
calls just
and that that was how we kind of so how
did you get your first yes and what did
it feel like and what was the process of
then taking a yes from a landlord to
then setting it up and making the kind
of profits you're making now the first
yes was through an agent so we saw the
agenda before them up and the first
property that was in Bedford to be
honest so that property in Bedford we
phoned up the agent and they said yeah
we do take company in it okay set the
process up and we we
um we already had company set up so
we've gone in you know go through the
normal process pay the the funds
required
and um
we we appoint a sa manager and then
essay manager decide you know we
confirmed we could do differentiation
for you and Justin junior said you know
that that's my fear I can do that myself
and and we we've done it really well to
the point where when the you know come
and have a look around they were so
pleased with what we've done so for the
first one we kind of get the understand
how to do it what we do what we expect
to see at the end result for me I I that
that's right up my street I love making
and doing and making things look how I
would have wanted it if I'm going in
there so I've always got it in my head
like if I was to stay here how would I
like it to be what would I appreciate
more or how would I just put myself in
there that's how I I dressed the
properties that I have how did you feel
when you got when you got a yes from an
agent oh no that was the best thing ever
what did they say what happened
so we rang up and we said is that
property available and they said yes and
we were like it's not going to be us
living there ourselves it'll be in a
company let and they said okay that's
fine we we do take them apparently we've
got one in the
building already so if we're familiar
with it and we're like yes who's on the
phone out of the two of you
I think that was myself you know really
I think it was myself it was him but um
when we get to the need to go to the
contract the contract says you can't
have it on Airbnb you can't have it and
it must be a minimum of five nine
initially it was 40 nights but we did
yeah we negotiate and get it down to
five nights and we were like no we're
not having it it's we can't we can't we
can't do this yeah 40 nights and minimum
14 nights day and we can't put in
booking.com okay they get back to us and
say okay we could do five nights minimum
five nights and um that that that we
decide initially we decide to to to walk
away from the deal and someone on the
mentor yeah no no no I was I was at a
course in Heathrow and I was expressing
it to it I couldn't remember and they
were like no speak to a mentor hear what
they say and I I think I spoke to
hustling and I was saying to her this is
the situation they wanted us to
guarantee that guests will be in there
five nights
minimum and
we can't guarantee that
on a company let because it's initially
going to be on Airbnb and she said
it is possible
just go for it
and so far we haven't had guest stars
booked more than two weeks that's the
minimum they've booked minimum of three
weeks minimum wow my charity monthly
booking monthly for that where is this
property in Bedford and and now I mean
that's the thing because a lot of people
think about Airbnb booking.com for
service accommodation short stay let's
they think they've got people coming in
for stag dues hen nights one two nights
but actually there's a lot of relocators
there's professionals contractors
exactly so two weeks is the minimum
minimum that's what we're getting and
how much are you how much you paying the
landlord
830 and how much are you charging on a
nightly basis that one is is with an
essay manager so we're kind of hands off
yeah
um um for me I was really scared because
that kind of five night was really scary
for me so I said to them this is the
situation and we hand it over to them
we've gone in 120 a night yeah and um as
a manager I think she started marketing
at 100 with discount
saying 25 discount of a book for the
whole month and that's what we start to
get pure monthly booking coming in for
but the thing is if they're paid 100 a
month 100 a night for the whole month
that's like three grand
and you're only paying the landlord
eight eight thirty eight thirty after
your bills and everything what's that
what are you left with profit on the
first month we we get
um
1200 1021 something for six week what
does it take when you saw that kind of
profit coming out it was baffling I was
like it was real this is real yeah it
does work it does work because for me
I'm a skeptic person I was like it's not
gonna work it's this it's a lie
yeah it's just too good to be true like
from that's me that's just my
personality you have to
um
dig deep you have to prove for me to
really really trust you and then when I
saw that it was like wow it does work it
does work and as soon as that one
starts bring in some funds we say
straight we go straight to Birmingham
and that one was direct to landlord yeah
yeah so you got another one how long did
it take to get straight off the back why
was it so quick the second time it's the
confidence yeah I think it's the
confidence because you you've done it
you can see that it's working and it's
just the confident that you have when
you approach people that yeah it yeah
you can do it like now this landlord is
calling us all the time we've got this
we've got that we're doing this we're
doing that yes how many how many
properties have you picked the keys
we've picked the keys up for four we've
got four keys so you've got four
properties at the moment yeah we've got
four properties live and one getting
ready in the next week or two have you
got the keys for that we haven't got we
haven't got the keys yet but we contract
everything agreed
um guarantor everything done so you've
got four at the moment
making you good money sort of two three
grand you got your fifth one going along
which is through my existing
um agent yeah the first agent and and
you're kind of full-time mom yeah how
many kids do you have I've got six kids
six kids wow the thing is it's not
practic in my opinion I don't think it's
practical to go to work every day
nine to five and then you've got the
travel on top
man and woman with kids at home
yeah it's not I just don't see how
people can do it you know we've got
young kids and when I went we're talking
about getting um one of our kids is
going to be going to Nursery or
preschool and we went and some of the
kids there were six months old at the
preschool and six months old and they're
and they're there 56 hours a week and
I'm thinking listen I'm not saying that
that's wrong but I personally I'm at
home all the time my wife's at home all
the time and I think being an
entrepreneur and having a business yes
it's hard yes it takes a lot of
persistence
um but it's worth it yes I think so as
well definitely hard definitely need the
persistence but if you put that work in
further the process I think it's going
to work out yeah and that's that's one
of the things I keep that's my belief I
never doubt it
since we start to get these rent to rent
just keep going how hard is the because
you've talked about the pain and the
suffering of getting your first yes the
rejection month after month once you've
got the keys and you've got the property
is it still painful or is did you find
that the setup process was also paying
for or was that easier on our first one
um setup was quite easy for that one
it we weren't because it was our first
one we we didn't know what we're doing
we buckled forward to the shop so it
took us a longer time do you think that
your first time round is always hardest
they just generally like you said that
when you got the keys to the first
property your confidence went up and I
think when you're not expecting a yes
and you're thinking oh they're gonna say
no they say no but when you get a yes
you then think oh well I'll keep getting
yeses and it's almost like what you
expect to happen what you believe you
almost manifest
if you're thinking this is too good to
be true this isn't going to work it's
almost like you know if you if you're
about to get married and you walk down
the aisle and you're saying this
marriage is going to fail this marriage
is going to fail you're doing it you
have to set that mindset yes the yes is
coming so what advice would you give
your self last year if you were speaking
to yourself from a year ago speaking to
myself last year when I
could only wish
our appearance
instill what we know now
and what advice I would have given
myself last year to compare to now just
I would have started earlier Omar start
earlier don't wait this long yeah for me
what advice I would give myself is
don't think that something is too good
to be true
yeah because if other people are doing
it there's no reason why you can't right
yeah there's no reason why you can't and
I find that for me I I find I make a lot
of excuses
a lot of excuses as to why I can't do
this and to why I can't do that and um
I'm just getting them a mindset reset if
that makes sense yeah as to this is
going to work I'm in property as well
we've noticed that with guests and
negative reviews and if it's not been
booked it's just having that mindset
that okay what can can I do it's not
what what's happening okay and I was I
was listening to the Rich Dad Poor Dad
but with my son and he was saying that
it don't
it's not what you have what you don't
have sorry what do you have that's what
he said what can I do it's not what I
can't do this so well it's what can I do
so start the reset of my mind
um that I would want to advise myself
yeah last year if that makes it great
absolutely what um what do you think has
differentiated you guys
with lots of people that attempt to be
successful in business I mean I think 90
I think it is a businesses fail within
the first five years
so why do you what do you think is
different about you guys why have you
been successful I think for me it's been
around other like-minded people
I started by saying that I know me if
I'm not in that environment I would just
Whittle away so for me I have to put
myself in that place where other people
are doing the same thing that I want to
do I often say to my kids that if you
want to do something if you want to be
something you have to find someone who's
done it who's doing it and see what
they're doing and copy them that's the
only way you're going to get to that
point and for us just being on crewing
um just speaking to other mental
speaking to the mentors you have taken
advantage of that speaking to the mentor
speaking to other company members and
coming on the academic course it's just
being around people who are doing it
yeah yeah that's I think that's really
important what would you would you say
Emma I think I would definitely agree
with what Julie is saying again it's
it's about mindset it it goes back to I
think she mentioned she said something
about copy just now and when I look back
and I see you know just by that first
one it's almost like a copy and paste
job we're doing going forward now yeah
so absolutely I totally agree with what
Julie's saying that's amazing what is it
that gives you your motivation what's
your drive what what kept you going
through all those no's
I think once worst for me is watching
that first video and we have to set why
are we doing it why are we doing this
what are your goals
and for me it's my kids
growing up
my family wasn't there for me it was
difficult and I need to set something
for my kids so at this minute we're
trying to build an Empire that's what
I'm looking at an Empire to leave for
them
yeah so that's that's kind of mine for
my why
um my husband is sickly so he's got
um sickle cell disease
he is the main Breadwinner can you
imagine the Panic he went into hospital
for eight days and it was like
he needs blood infusion they're going to
stop and start his heart all this kind
of thing and I was like I didn't have a
dad
um
God forbid if anything should happen to
him what have I got in place for my kids
and it's like I need to know that if
he's not here
the kids are okay we're not struggling
like I struggle I mean we grew up in
Jamaica my mom was a single mom he was a
better off I often said to him and tease
him like what does he see me because his
family had money my family was poor so
it was like I definitely would not
absolutely want my kids to go through
this
and that's my why and that's what keeps
me going even when I'm slowing down
and it's
it's not going how I wanted to wanted to
go I just pick myself up and
think like okay this is why you're doing
it this is why you're doing it remember
where you're coming from remember how it
was hard for you
and that's my why
ask my why well I think that's really
powerful and I think that you know
you're gonna you're gonna definitely
leave that Legacy for your kids but not
just your kids because even within the
academy you guys are such a bright light
and you're so humble like you sit there
or you're crewing or you're being an
event and there'll be all these other
Academy members and I don't think people
know because you're just there asking
questions and people don't realize
actually these guys have got a whole
bunch of rent to rents and they're
making very good money yeah I don't
think people quite realize over a short
period of time three months yeah we've
only gone in here for three months yeah
give also for a year two years you know
we just started yeah so there's many
more to come I would say because I was
like oh we're not ready yet to go on
winners on a Wednesday I I would say
that because
I haven't done your course Justice
because there's so much that you've
advised and it's
if you take it on you take it on if you
don't then it's your decision but
there's so much that you advise that if
I was to like doing it to the book to
the T we would have been so much further
so
um my
proposal to use that once we are
where I think in my head where I know
actually let's rephrase it I'll be in
like six months then we'll come back
into 100 100 we can definitely do a part
two yes because it's already what you've
achieved is incredible you know fifth
rent to rent now thousands of pounds a
month coming in you've systemized it
nicely how much time do you have to
spend managing the portfolio I I would
say probably 10 hours a week yeah it's
the cleaners it's the cleaners
they're what they do everything those
the cleaners that you need to manage
more than anything else yeah what's the
top tips then from finding and managing
cleaners that's the hardest part that is
hard finding a good cleaner
we we've kind of what
interview free so far for the permanent
project and
they were difficult to find but in the
end find a lady who is really on top she
she's she's good enough for us yeah
definitely what advice would I give
um I have them there see let them see
what you are like what your personality
is
um what your standards are yeah and and
just
let them know that I say this already
that this is just think about it like I
I'm moving in I'm going in there so it's
always I put myself in there and I'm
thinking if it's not good enough for me
then yeah I don't want it to be for
anybody on my essays and I think what
you set out again in the first bit of
the rent to rent um accelerator online
version was what are you aiming for a
luxury a basic yeah and we we get we
went for the Lux review yeah so where
are your properties so we've got one in
Bedford that's the first one the second
one in Birmingham city center the third
one in Buckingham that's where we live
and the fourth one in Milton Keynes
Wolverton nice and the fifth is Brighton
right now okay so they're kind of a
little bit scattered yeah yeah but
mostly begin with with a baby mostly
that's what our kids say we need the
best of now and then yeah yeah
what do your family think about what
you've done
oh gosh family I think once we bought
our
second home in Jamaica then we'll say
this is what we've done from it you know
yeah but then a lot of people I think
would listen to their loved ones and if
they were about to go you know pursue a
career invest in a program and then all
their family were saying don't do it
don't do it don't do it you know
from day one it's been us
um when we have kids and we're really
struggling they were a little on top of
each other I had five children or four
children three children on the five at
one point and it was like it's just us
no one no no we don't really need to
yeah we never had a grandmother
grandparents around yeah my mom passed
when I was 10. her mom is still living
in Jamaica we just never had a family
around us yeah even though my my
my dad's side of family we got half
living over here in the UK half living
in Jamaica because home a Granddad
structured his family you know wife in
Jamaica so you got half a family they
got Mrs silver here half a family here
but we never we never we just never
closed they never support us yeah I
remember we when we just started God one
of my aunt said don't grow up with this
girl find somebody else
wow and now look big beautiful family
and now part of a big Academy family
exactly yeah which I think he's one of
the most from what I've heard from what
you're saying the academy is not just
about education it's also about support
and the environment the family the
community the community exactly
exactly yeah so what would be your final
um words of wisdom listen to your gut
instinct I don't think this is for
everyone because I don't think
everyone's going to put the work in yeah
um if you know you've got a reason why
you need to come out of what you're in
or you're not content of if
for for whatever reason you know you you
just know within yourself that this is
not
where I am at now it's not where I
should be just try property because it's
it wasn't my initial thing I was like
okay I'll come with you to the course
and um
it's the best thing I'm not gonna lie
um the knowledge like there's so many
things that we know now that we didn't
know
last year yeah
and the knowledge is when you have
knowledge of confidence when you've got
confident you can do anything that's
what I believe that's the advice that I
can give yeah yeah yeah
and probably for me you know a lot of
people sit in the comfort zone I work in
the corporate industry for a long way
you know a long while and
you work you get paid
easy money to do whatever and some
people will never get out of that
situation because they don't have the
mindset to say you know what I want that
change
believing that you know just work is
going to continue to give them what they
want or it's gonna give them that
lifestyle they want yes everybody
lifestyle is different but for me
um I always try to aim higher and
um
it's
it would be you know advising someone to
say you know what if you've got
instincts say you want to get out of a
situation
go for it because not everyone got
interesting and say get out some people
are going to say no I'm in the situation
I'm going to stay in this situation or I
don't want to stay in but I'm not
risking going into something I'm unsure
about but not until you you've gone in
been around the environment seeing the
people you're working with
and saranya said for those type of
people then you know you're in the right
place yeah I know you guys now you also
want you want to stop building your
portfolio and doing developments and
Commercial work conversions and stuff
definitely is that the fact definitely I
have been to a lot of ppns and at the
minute um I'm kind of I'm pushing to the
commercial development permanent
development side we've just secured one
depends how it goes oh you just secured
One Secured one with the letting agents
so is this a property to buy it's a
property to buy here and and how are you
going to be financing it I'm looking
either at a development loan or a
bridging cool what about the deposit
I've got um investors who said they will
put some money up front Okay well if you
need any help with that
speak to me man because I love you guys
you know it's literally right up our
street as well where we
a little bit of background I used to
be a hairdresser
I used to
um
have a food trailer so I mean when I was
growing up I hated cooking I hated
everything to do with the kitchen it
just makes you stink because I used to
cook on the wood fire so it's Smoky
everywhere
so we came and we started up this food
business and we started this food
business and it was like it was doing
well it was amazing it was it was
amazing and we had it working on Bright
Now
and it was it was just
hard work overwhelmed I was just shocked
because I couldn't cook growing up and
people now come and tell me that they
love my food it's like wow what happened
anyway
this particular property that we're
looking at is an all Co-op
okay so um we've contacted the seller
and they've they're what what offer did
you put in again um initially I I've
gone in with the full offer 475 however
on The Mastermind last night not in the
Market at this minute I've kind of not
we joined my offer but
um say to them that I will send through
a revised offer and the reviser was
subject to my gdv and um build cost and
so on yeah so yeah yeah because
basically yesterday I banned people from
paying the because the Market's changed
so much to a bias Market Adam in a year
good oh what I'm really interested in
how it works out yeah because this
property
um we were planning to split it up in
three different smaller shops at the
bottom and then two
top yeah so we were thinking should I go
back into Jamaican but we don't know
Jamaica let's discuss to be continued
winners Wednesday part two coming guys
you're awesome thanks for coming on the
show I hope you've enjoyed it and I
appreciate you sharing the light thank
you so much
um we feel so privileged to be here
honestly
honestly to admit you are um if you're
such an inspiring person and you're not
lazy and that's what
um we were brought up to be not lazy but
you come here and it's like you get
comfortable yeah and it's like okay I
can relax but I've never seen like when
we were 11 you were just a baby yeah can
you imagine are you such an
inspirational person to us is like wow
we were 11 and you were a baby and
you've taught us so much I mean I am
so inspired by you I appreciate it thank
you I'm inspired by you guys too thank
you so much thank you so much